nous en rejoint pour la revue presse
[Musique]
bonjour axel siège de kiev a commencé à
la une de nombreux journaux du monde ce
matin prions pour kiev titre en une le
daily mail qui assurent même qui va
jusqu'à assurer que le kremlin a ordonné
à ses 3 millions d'habitants les 3000
habitants de kiev deux parties ont de
faire face à des bombardements mais
quelques heures après l'avertissement
effrayant poursuit le daily mail un
missile a détruit le principal émetteur
de télévision de la ville on le voit là
à l'image tuant cinq civils le daily
mail poursuit l'attak a également
endommagé le mémorial juifs édifié en
souvenir de l'un des plus grands
massacres nazis de la seconde guerre
mondiale et cette allusion à la seconde
guerre mondiale on la retrouve en une du
daily express qui titre sur le blitz
vous savez cette campagne de
bombardements menés par l'aviation
allemande contre le royaume uni lors de
la seconde guerre mondiale et donc là on
voit en une du daily express est
bombardé mais jamais battu et puis
regardez enfin la presse espagnol el
mundo
poutine qui écrase kiev pour mettre à
genoux les alinsky zaleski volodymyr
valider ce qui bien sûr le président
ukrainien cette offensive a des
conséquences immédiates des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui fuient chaque
jour l'ukraine on est là c'est
libération qui titre sur ses sept cent
mille réfugiés ukrainien le déchirement
scènes de panique familles séparées dans
tout le pays des foules apeurée tenté
hier de prendre un train pour échapper
aux bombardements rue est désespérée
pour le dernier train de kiev là c'est
le guardian regardez témoigne une
ukrainienne dans les colonnes du journal
britannique regardez ces visages autour
de nous ils sont exactement les mêmes
que sur les photographies de la seconde
guerre mondiale mais cette vingt et la
guerre vient cette fois par les
caricaturistes de presse et soudain un
nouvel ordre mondial placé le temps le
journal suisse qui publie cette image
qui veut tout dire un char allant en
direction de kiev caricature aussi en
une du corriere della serra avec
vladimir poutine qui marche sur des
crânes et ce titre la via della guerra
la route de la guerre et puis et puis
l'humour qui permet de rire plus
franchement là c'est l'équipe qui
s'amusent qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de
tout ça demande un russe à propos de la
russie qui mise au ban du monde sportif
et on voit plein de produits dopants et
l'un des ses collègues lui répond eh
bien l exporter en chine mon âge il a
prescrit ce matin
le moscow times publie la tribune d'un
ancien diplomate britannique qui déclare
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie
apparaît comme une erreur une grande
erreur stratégique et il ya une certaine
un certain courage a publié comme ça
quand on est un journal russe une
tribune aussi vindicatif puisque le
kremlin a fait bloquer une télévision
indépendante et une station de radio
libéral pour avoir diffusé selon la
terminologie utilisée par moscou des
fausses informations sur l'invasion de
l'ukraine novaïa gazeta publié un
éditorial et expliquant nous considérons
le brouillage d'écho de moscou et puis 2
days comme une ingérence flagrante dans
les activités des médias et on voit ce
stylo plume et gars dont la fin se
termine en fil barbelé les débrancher
assez collé des bâillons à des dizaines
de millions de citoyens russes rapporte
de leur côté à la chaîne russia today y
est le site spoutnik qui sont les voix
de la russie à l'étranger sont visés par
des mesures de rétorsion de l'union
européenne très rapidement cette guerre
écrase toute l'actualité notamment
l'actualité politique en france oui mais
très rapidement la une du figaro qui est
aussi axé sur macro dans la bataille
diplomatique
la campagne présidentielle est éclipsé
et c'est ce que résume aussi l'opinion
derrière l'ukraine il y à la
présidentielle sachant qu'en principe
emmanuel macron devrait pourrait
annoncer officiellement sa candidature
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup axel rester avec nous je
vous retrouve dans quelques minutes pour
la suite ne paraît direct la dernière
demi heure d'information a tout de suite
[Musique]